foreign
[Music]
did you know that a dragon from A Song
of Ice and Fire has a dinosaur that is
named after it well let's take a look
into the dragon add a dinosaur in this
video
let's start with the dragon despite not
appearing in Game of Thrones or House of
the Dragon this dragon is still well
known in the franchise miraxius was a
she dragon and during aegon's Conquest
Queen Reign is Targaryen wrote her
alongside King aegon the conquerors
balerion and queen vicenius vegar
miraxis was named after one of the old
Valyrian Gods she was bigger than Vega
but not as big as Valerian at her time
of death but later on Vega due to her
living longer eventually outgrew miraxis
she was capable of swallowing horses
whole which means she was very large
probably in the 60 meters or 200 feet
range she also had silver scales and
golden eyes
was key in the conquest of the Seven
Kingdoms and was used widely by aegon to
subdue his enemies in the war she proved
to be a terrifying force in the field of
fire where alongside the other two
dragons they burned 5 000 soldiers and
achieved a decisive Victory against the
Lannisters but her untimely death came
at the first Danish War when she was
sent to Dawn and a large scorpion bolt
which was like an oversized crossbow
arrow was shot at her and pierced her
eye into her head sending both a dragon
and her Rider to death
now let's take a look at the dinosaur
maraxis is a carcarcharodontosaurus
Genus from Argentina's late Cretaceous
Period marax's gigas is the only species
in the genus the holotype specimen
mmch.pv65 was discovered in 2012 and was
previously known as the campanas kakaro
dontosaurin a nearly complete skull a
pectoral and pelvic elements partial for
limbs complete hilums fragmentary ribs
and cervical and dorsal vertebrae a
sacrum and several complete Coral
vertebrae were among the known bones
discovered there it possesses the most
complete kakara daughter sword skeleton
found in the southern hemisphere
maraxis was a massive theropod that
weighed approximately 4.26 metric tons
its skull alone is 1.27 meters of 4.2
feet long rivaling acroganthosaurus
which has a 1.23 meter skull length of 4
feet this means that the dinosaur was
around 10 to 11 meters or 33 to 36 feet
long and probably around 3.5 meters or
11.5 feet tall at the hips maraxis and
acroganthosaurus had similar proportions
and body size based on the shapes and
proportions of the various bones it also
had shot of four limbs which was the
result of conversion evolution in four
different lineages gakara Don sarde
Abella sarde Tyrannosaur day and Alvarez
sorry day according to the holotype the
individual could have been up to 53
years old when it died having reached
skeletal maturity approximately four
years before death making it the
longest-lived non-avian teleport ever
known it would have lived around 95 to
93 million years ago long before the
mapusaurus another giant dinosaur that
roamed the same geographical area it
would have hunted smaller herbivores
iguanodons ceratopsians and even large
sauropods like the Argentinosaurus
but only the young old and sickly
individuals as these long necks were
vastly larger and more powerful than a
dinosaur which had a dragon name
so as to why this dinosaur had the name
moraxis well at the time of discovery of
the bones Game of Thrones had just
finished with its second season and the
world of A Song of Ice and Fire was fast
becoming one of the best-selling books
worldwide and it was exploding all over
the Internet which included stories
about aegon the Conqueror and the Three
Dragons which were valerion vegar and
moraxis and although not being as big or
as terrifying as a fantasy Dragon this
large carnivorous dinosaur they had the
same name as the dragon of Queen reynus
due to Fantastical timing of the
discovery
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel take care
fam